is my idea good
i get asked this so many times from
different entrepreneurs who are trying
to launch a new company they're unsure
of themselves unsure of what they're
doing and they want
proof for me
that they should keep going they should
launch this thing
i'd like to flip the question on you
guys okay this is really important
because you can make money in any
industry any industry out there you can
make money in it if that's what you're
trying to do you can have success and
money in any industry
to make that happen
you have to bring yourself into it you
have to be super passionate about what
you're doing
and you have to bring a twist that other
people haven't done before
and that's going to be hard
that's going to force people to change
their habits there's going to be a lot
of resistance there's going to be a lot
of people who say no to you and you have
to be willing to suffer through all that
to eventually build your company
so for all of these ideas
they could be great
but do you have the passion behind it
and the fortitude
and conviction to stay with it
because if you do
it's fantastic if you don't the best
idea in the world will never go anywhere
i got a question from one of my readers
uh seth he's actually a youtube viewer
love you guys
seth is a student i want to open up his
own winery in michigan
and once eventually have his own winery
and sell the land underneath to sell the
condos and wanted my advice on it was a
good idea and what to do next
so why are you doing this seth what's
the reason for starting this business do
you love wine
are you passionate about wine do you
have a view of the way wineries should
be built that is different than what's
happening now
do you love helping people pick what
wine they should drink
and have opinions on
what wine goes with what food and and
why people are doing this all wrong if
you have that passion if you love wine
then go for it
this could be for you it's a great
opportunity you can make money in the
wine business
but if you're just trying to do it
because you think hey people spend a lot
of money on wine
i could sell this off in a couple years
do something else you probably won't
have a lot of success
so i'd examine your core reasons
if the reasons are good well-intentioned
want to make a difference want to help
people
then do it
and you'll have success
in terms of next steps seth said he was
uh trying to get a job at a winery to
learn the business and wanted my advice
on what to do
and that's the perfect way to do it you
know seth he's just graduating from
university looking for his first job
the best way to learn about the industry
is to go work in the industry
right for him to go and set up his own
winery right now would be
massively risky he doesn't know what
he's doing never had a business before
never been in the wine industry to set
up your own vineyard is going to cost
tons of money
and the chances of him being successful
will be tiny because he's never done it
before
but if you go work at a winery i would
pick a winery where you can connect with
the entrepreneur you believe in what
they're doing
they're willing to show you the ropes
you get involved as much as you can you
learn from them you learn not only the
job that you're hired for but you take
on extra projects every entrepreneur is
understaffed
so if you come in and you're a star
employee and you want to do more work
you want to help them with projects that
are outside your domain because you want
to learn
a good boss will give it to you so
that's the kind of person you want to go
work for i would be highly selective
of who you go work for and make sure
it's somebody who's going to give you
opportunities because you are taking
this job not to make money
it'll help keep you you know afloat but
that's not the main goal the goal is to
learn the goal is to get experience
supposed to get contacts the goal is to
make mistakes while getting paid this is
your real education this is your real
university
to give you the confidence contacts
experience so when you're ready to go
launch your own thing you know what to
do
i think you're on the right track
but again is it a good idea or not
only you can really answer that question
if you're in this for the right reasons
and it sounds like it that you are from
the passion you wrote in your in your
message
but that's going to be the real test
and for anybody else who's thinking the
same thing who's who's doubting
themselves and doubting their own ideas
and trying to get outsiders to give them
i guess encouragement and confidence
that hey somebody else believes in my
idea
the answer really lies within because
nobody can tell you if this is a good
business or not
it could be a great opportunity but if
you're not committed to it it's not
going to work and and you could take an
industry that's in the dumps where
nobody's making money on it and turn it
around into a great business
if you have the passion and conviction
fortitude to leg it out
believe
those you're watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and i
would love to hear what you have to
think leave a comment let me know what's
on your mind you have a question leave
it below i'll make a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon